the Philadelphia Flyers recently
unveiled a new mascot and the mascots
name is gritty it's true story yeah now
from the start this mascot really
divided people
some think that gritties cute other
people think he's terrifying it's kind
of a news story see for yourself there
is gritty yeah and everyone's saying
it's hard to tell exactly what gritty is
supposed to be is the a Muppet is the
Yeti is he some kind of Bigfoot nobody
has any idea now gritty has made some
appearances on local and national TV but
one thing no one has done yet is
interview the person inside the gritty
costume to find out more about gritty we
wanted to be the first that's why we
flew him in from Philadelphia so he
could be here tonight from the
Philadelphia Flyers pretty the mascot
[Applause]
pretty
welcome to California thanks for coming
out yeah okay great now what we'd love
to do is speak with please stop that
what we'd like to do is speak with the
person inside Gritti so if you don't
mind can you do that
there we go oh that's kind of nice
actually it gets really hot in there oh
my god I'm sorry you just you caught me
off guard oh don't worry same same oh I
completely understand I mean people see
this big crazy costume and then they see
my real face and they're not quite ready
for the contract no that wasn't it no I
think we were all expecting a bigger
contrast between gritty and the real you
all right I got it because of the facial
hair yeah I came from the airport and
didn't get to shave no no no no okay
tell me this where did you work before
you started playing gritty oh you know
mostly over the phone stuff a little
over a little postmates I'm a part-time
paramedic but but now with this I really
feel like I found my true calling well
it's okay stop that it's a it's a
perfect fit and I just want to thank you
for dropping by nice - oh thanks so much
for having me nice
employers night
[Applause]
you